vous savez ce qui va se passer eh bien
nous allons bientôt manquer de l'eau et
c'est pourquoi je bois devant vous un
verre d'eau précieuse puisque avant la
fin du siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera
à lundi je vous dis au revoir et
j'espère vous revoir pour vous expliquer
notre projet global d'avenir merci mes
amis
rené dumont premier candidat écologiste
à l'élection présidentielle
vous en avez le souvenir jean lassalle
parfaite demain et je trouve que c'est
une
des images cultes de l'ina si je les vus
et revus à plusieurs reprises
permettez moi de me distinguer toutefois
un peu de lui parce que bien sûr je je
je je vois ce sont un terreau
visionnaire mais je n'ai jamais eu par
rapport à ça un caractère aussi
définitif est désespérée peut-être parce
que j'avais lu la bible comme j'ai vu le
capital ou
et dans la bible
est un passage roues il est question du
grenelle et le guen là ça veut dire la
bande verte à l'anglais choquant moi qui
n'ai jamais fais engueuler mais plutôt
l'espagnol qu'on vous l'avez rappelé il
semblerait que le guen là c'était pas
que là était une bande ou des cavaliers
se déplacer à bride abattue dans des
nuages de poussière je trouve que
aujourd'hui on manque peut être un peu
trop de climatologues je n'ai suivi un
certain nombre pour démontrer que sur
des périodes courtes les climats en
beaucoup le climat a beaucoup changé
mais moins au lieu de me suicider au de
m tel père tel stress dans la nuit
demande déjà assez
préoccupés par tous je préférerais qu'on
met 1 5% à la recherche fondamentale la
recherche appliquée pour trouver au plus
vite l'énergie de deux mèches quoi
qu'elle sera solaire comme le fond
romain comme le laboratoire de forum à
perpignan ou alors l'énergie des marées
mélenchon qui est le candidat le plus
expérimenté avec moi en parle lui aussi
imaginer que nous avons 11 millions de
kilomètres carrés grâce
à nos cotes la chine ne fait que 8
millions de kilomètres carrés est ce que
vous voyez l'espace que nous avons pour
essayer de voir ce fait pas quelque
chose entre avec la différence thermique
qu'il existe entre la surface des flots
et celle qui lie à 2000 m 2 sous je veux
que la france se dote et soit la
première à trouver l'énergie
2 mais totalement renouvelable si je
vous ai bien entendu jean lassalle vous
vous contester l'idée que la terre se
réchauffe sous l'effet des activités
humaines en tout cas vous partager
l'idée qu'il y a des des cycles de
réchauffement et de refroidissement qui
sont indépendants de de l'activité
humaine sur la terre
écoutez je ne peux pas contester parce
que je ne suis pas assez
je vois un chevronné en la matière pour
ça il y à doc avait singh et les images
que vous montrer
que je suis président des populations
des montagnes du monde je vois à travers
les montagnes effectivement une chose
que les glaciers mais bien d'autres
choses changer mais en tout cas si tel
est le cas on se trompe totalement
d'adressent en accusant les hommes et
les femmes sont obligées de se servir de
leurs moteurs diesel dans nos campagnes
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le choix nous
avons beaucoup parlé nous avons beaucoup
sauter comme des cabris sur nos chaises
qu'on visait le général sur l'énergie
mais qu'avons nous fait rien en tout cas
si la planète à
bouger c'est plus tôt sous l'effet des
salopards il ya
construit des bénéfices monstrueux avec
des actions qui ne respectent rien
[Musique]